so the ukrainian town of aviv near the
polish border has been spared the brunt
of the fighting but has been flooded
with refugees fleeing russia's onslaught
lucas tomlinson is at his post yet again
today and we check in live with you and
lucas good morning there as you get
ready for another day hello
bill good morning officials tell me that
a no-fly zone over this country would
have no effect on some of the 500
ballistic and short-range and cruise
missiles that are flying into this
country that have no effect whatsoever
now we just got this video in from
chernahev located two hours north of the
capital a city that has largely been
reduced to rubble now earlier ukraine's
president zielinski addressed the
european continent
do not be silent support ukraine because
if ukraine does not survive the whole of
europe will not survive if ukraine falls
the whole of europe will fall
tens of thousands of people poured out
on the streets of prague earlier to hear
zielinski's virtual address this is that
convoy remains stalled outside the
capitol many analysts wondering bill
where are the russian soldiers in that
convoy why don't sad images ever show
people outside the vehicles that you
would expect that of any kind of
military convoy that's parked if there
are reports there are reports there's
low morale among those soldiers they're
eating expired food we spoke to one
woman earlier on the streets here who
said that her mother lives near that
convoy and has had russian soldiers
coming into her home and ransacking her
food here in la vie we traveled 30
minutes north of here and saw a former
american soldier training with foreign
fighters he offered this explanation for
russia's military problems in this
country
the ukrainians have killed a lot of
russians in this past week and i'm
surprised how fast the russians want to
throw their troops behind enemy lines to
die
now we passed a number of checkpoints
going up in the city this is a
university town bill as i've mentioned
before however once you leave the city
we traveled 30 minutes north from here
go through numerous checkpoints you see
a lot of local militias citizen soldiers
men building sandbags and many just
armed with hunting rifles standing a
watch standing a post clearly on a
wartime footing some of those fighters
said they had seen some russian gunships
flying overhead bill um lucas your
background is in the military u.s navy
and i just want to draw on that because
there were military experts earlier
today suggesting that the russians have
supplies and fuel that will get them to
sunday which means two days from now
are you hearing that and
if so what can you report on that if
true
well certainly we're talking about the
convoy in this stalled convert there are
certainly a lot of questions about the
fuel issues and also the the mud the
fact that these uh vehicles that are
supposed to be this supposed to be an
all-weather force bill and the fact that
they have to stick to the main roads is
certainly raising questions you know
those tanks you know should be able to
you know go through any kind of land and
certainly this uh rich farmland here in
ukraine in terms of warships bill off
the coast of odessa we're starting to
get some reporting in that some of those
ships might have turned around gone back
to crimea but as you know just a couple
days ago we first reported that a group
of russian warships had left crimea and
are posed to do an amphibious assault in
odessa uh ukraine's third largest city
however there are some reporting tonight
from ukrainian officials that some of
the ships may have turned around so we
don't know if that's a diversion tactic
perhaps you mentioned curse on that city
north of crimea would some soldiers be
coming down there but again back to your
logistical problems and fuel is this
russian army capable of moving that far
bill great point uh lucas one last thing
here i have described this putin march
as slow slower than he wants steady but
deliberate would you agree with that
i think i like slow and steady in terms
of deliberate i think when you look at
some of the tactics the shelling of
civilian areas you know missile cruise
missiles flying into apartment buildings
indiscriminate shelling with artillery
and from some of the jet aircraft bill i
would say this is looking like grozny
and and chesnia and parts of syria
perhaps aleppo so i'm not so
deliberately
officials would say deliberately evil
targeting civilian areas yeah with
intent on that lucas thank you nice to
see you great work over there lucas hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else